♪ ♪
>> Tucker: AS WE TOLD YOU AT
THE TOP RIGHT BEFORE WE CAME ON
THE AIR TONIGHT THAT ACTRESS
ROSE McGOWAN WANTED TO COME ON
TO TALK ABOUT SOMETHING.
WE'VE NEVER MET ROSE McGOWAN
BEFORE BUT WE ARE COMPLETELY
OPEN MINDED.
WE JUST LEARNED ABOUT SOMETHING
WITH BRITNEY SPEARS WHO WE HAVE
NOT INTERVIEWED SINCE SHE WAS
LITERALLY A TEENAGER.
APPARENTLY SHE IS UNDER A
CONSERVATORSHIP FOR THE PAST 13
YEARS AND THIS HAS BEEN IN THE
NEWS.
FLEW UNDER OUR RADAR, BUT IT HAS
BEEN.
AND ROSE McCOWAN HAS BEEN
WATCHING IT ALSO AND HAS
THOUGHTS ABOUT IT.
SHE JOINS US NOW.
ROSE McGOWAN, THANKS SO MUCH
FOR COMING ON TONIGHT.
>> HI, TUCKER.
NICE TO MEET YOU TOO.
I ALSO HAVE AN OPEN MIND.
HE WAS MY FAVORITE QUALITY AS A
FIRST FOR HIS SAFETY.
I'M COMING AT THIS COLD.
I AGAIN HAVEN'T SEEN
BRITNEY SPEARS SINCE 2003.
I JUST HEARD SHE HAS BEEN UNDER
CONSERVATORSHIP.
MAKE THE CASE, IF YOU WOULD.
WHAT IS IT AND WHY IS THAT BAD
OR GOOD?
>> WELL, IN MY OPINION AND IN
MANY OTHER'S, IMAGINE YOU ARE A
25-YEAR-OLD YOUNG WOMAN OR YOUNG
HUMAN WHO HAS BEEN FORCED TO
PERFORM SINCE AS LONG AS SHE
COULD WALK TO SUPPORT HER
FAMILY.
HER FATHER PUT HER UNDER A
CONSERVATORSHIP AT AGE 25.
MANY IN THE MEDIA LAUGHED AND
SCORNED HER WHEN SHE SHAVED HER
HEAD.
I LIVED IN HOLLYWOOD DURING THAT
TIME AND I MADE IT MY LIFE'S
MISSION TO TELL ALL OF YOU OUT
THERE WHAT SO MANY OF YOU REALLY
KNOW DEEP DOWN.
THAT FAME AT HOLLYWOOD AND THE
MEDIA MACHINE ARE ROTTEN TO THE
CORE.
AND THEY DO HURT AND THEY DO
DAMAGE.
AT AGE 25, HER FATHER AND A
JUDGE RULED WITH MANY PAID OFF
DOCTOR'S HELP THAT
BRITNEY SPEARS HAD DEMENTIA.
SO, SINCE THEN, SHE HAS GONE ON
TO DO A FIVE YEAR IN VEGAS.
SHE HAS GONE ON A TOUR.
WHAT HAPPENED TODAY IS LITERALLY
A CULTURAL LANDMARK MOMENT.
IT IS A CULTURAL RESET.
SHE GOT TO SPEAK FOR THE FIRST
TIME I BELIEVE IN HER LIFE.
WHAT HAS BEEN DONE TO HER IS
HORRIFIC.
AND I KNOW IT SEEMS LIKE WHY
SHOULD WE CARE ABOUT A RICH POP
PRINCESS, RIGHT?
BUT I THINK IT IS DEEPER THAN
THAT AND I THINK IT GOES TO WHAT
YOU TALKED ABOUT, WHICH IS THE
ROCK AND THE MACHINE AND HOW
SOCIETY ALSO PLAYS A PART IN A
WE WEIRD FORM OF OPPRESSION.
IT'S THE ONE MAN, YOU HAVE
PUSHED ALL MY BUTTONS, I HAVE TO
SAY.
THE IDEA THAT THE INDIVIDUAL IS
CRUSHED BY FORCING LARGER AND
DEEP DOWN IT REALLY IS ROTTEN
AND PEOPLE ARE TREATED AS
DISPOSABLE OBJECTS RATHER THAN
AS HUMAN BEINGS WITH SOULS.
I MEAN, THAT IS ON DISPLAY EVERY
SINGLE DAY.
PARDON MY IGNORANCE, BUT
QUICKLY, CONSERVATORSHIP MEANS
SHE CAN'T MAKE BASIC LIFE
DECISIONS FOR HERSELF?
>> ABSOLUTELY NONE.
SHE CAN MAKE NO DECISIONS.
WHEN SHE SEES HER KIDS, WHAT
MEDICINE SHE TAKES.
SHE SAID TODAY, BRITNEY SPEARS
SAID THEY PUT HER ON LITHIUM.
THAT IS AN INCREDIBLY HELPFUL
DRUG FOR SOME, BUT A HARD-CORE
DRUG.
SHE SAID SHE WAS DOPED OUT.
I'M SUMMARIZING.
SHE, I THINK IS READY TO BLOW
THE LID.
SHE SAID TODAY SHE IS SO ANGRY,
IT'S INSANE.
AND I UNDERSTAND THAT KIND OF
RAGE AFTER BEING --
SORRY, GO AHEAD.
>> Tucker: NO, NO, NO, I
DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING.
I'M LISTENING INTENTLY.
>> OH, SORRY.
SO, THE THING IS, I WAS THE
FIRST ONE TO GO ON THE RECORD
ABOUT HARVEY WEINSTEIN AND THAT
KIND OF SICKNESS.
AND THE PEOPLE THAT ARE TRULY
PUTTING YOUR ENTERTAINMENT IN
YOUR HEAD.
WHILE WE HAVE ALL BEEN
ENTERTAINED BY BRITNEY SPEARS,
SHE HAS BEEN BEING TORTURED.
AND I KNOW IT SEEMS LIKE ONE
PERSON.
BUT THEY HAVE DONE THIS TO WOMEN
AND HUMANS AND WHISTLE-BLOWERS,
AND PEOPLE THEY DON'T LIKE.
AND LIKE YOU SAID, TUCKER, THE
PEOPLE, THE MONSTERS IN POWER
THAT CONTROL THE PUPPETS, NOT
JUST HER.
BUT THE MESSAGE IT SENDS TO
EVERY GIRL OR EVERY BOY OUT
THERE I'M A ARE DISPOSABLE AND
THE ELITE CAN OWN YOU.
>> Tucker: SO I THINK IT
MATTERS.
I DO.
I THINK THE INDIVIDUAL MATTERS
ABOVE ALL.
AND IF THEY CAN DESTROY ONE
PERSON, THEY CAN DESTROY
EVERYONE.
I KNOW NOTHING BUT WHAT YOU JUST
TOLD ME.
BUT I THINK YOU MAKE A REALLY
COMPELLING CASE.
I LOVE THAT YOU CARE AND I'M
REALLY GLAD THAT YOU CAME ON
TONIGHT.
ROSE McGOWAN, THANK YOU VERY